بعض الأخبار التي يحتمل أن تكون جيدة لمن
يطلق عليهم فيروس كورونا النافذ لمسافات طويلة ،
تتحسن بعض أعراضهم
بعد حصولهم على اللقاح ،
وقد كانت هذه الأعراض واسعة النطاق مما
يجعل من الصعب على خبراء الصحة
تحديد الموقف المحبط للغاية
للمرضى.
في الشهر الماضي ، تحدثت إلى إد
هورنك صاحب المسافات الطويلة وأخبرنا أنه عانى
من ضباب الدماغ المنهك
والصداع والتعب لأكثر من عام
ووصفه بأنه يوم جرذ الأرض
يستيقظ دون معرفة ما إذا كان سيختفي أبدًا.
يتصارع الكثير من الناقلين لمسافات طويلة
مثلي ،
هل نحن معاقون بشكل دائم أم
أننا نعلم أننا
سنستيقظ يومًا ما ونكتشف أن لدينا كل هذه الطاقة وهذا شيء رائع حقًا وقد
انضم إلي إد هورنيك الآن  حسنًا ، لقد
حصلت على الجرعة الأولى من اللقاح ،
هل استيقظت بعد ولديك
كل هذه الطاقة كما كنت
تأمل
أنها حدثت بالفعل كما
قلت في أذني  بيان ليير رائع ،
لقد كان ممتعًا للغاية لأنني تلقيت
الجرعة الأولى من لقاح فايزر في
الثامن من مارس
وكان لدي رد فعل قوي جدًا تجاهه ، فقد
كنت
أعاني من أعراض تشبه أعراض الأنفلونزا لمدة أسبوع تقريبًا
كنت في السرير تقريبًا لمدة أسبوع تقريبًا  أسبوعًا
ثم
في ليلة الجمعة حتى يوم السبت ،
استيقظت وكان لدي كل هذه الطاقة
ولاحظت أن
ضباب عقلي قد تبدد
ولاحظت أن لدي المزيد من الطاقة للتو
شعرت بأنني صافية وشعرت أنني
كنت قادرًا على ذلك
نوعًا ما ضع الأشياء معًا مرة أخرى في
رأسي وكان
نوعًا من تجربة فتح العين
لأنني
رأيت للتو قصة آه أنت تعرف في المنشور
عن
أه بعض الأشخاص الآخرين الذين يسعون لمسافات طويلة لديهم
تجارب متشابهة جدًا
وآه كنت مثل  هذا يحدث
لي أه ما زلت أعرف بعض التعب
وبعض الأشياء الأخرى ،
أنت تعرف بعضًا طويل المدى ، أنت تعرف
الأعراض
ولكن آه في الغالب أعني أن
ضباب الدماغ
قد ذهب وهو ما لا يمكنني حتى إخبارك
بما  إنها معجزة
بالتأكيد وأنا أعلم عندما ر
في المرة الأخيرة التي شعرت فيها بالخوف ، لم تكن
تعلم
ما إذا كان سيختفي ، لذا
كانت هذه هي المرة الأولى منذ أن
تعاقدت مع الطمع حقًا ، وفي
النهاية ذهب ضباب الدماغ
واستيقظت بالطاقة بشكل صحيح
، لقد كان الأمر هادئًا  شعور غريب
لأنني لم أشعر بهذه الطريقة على
الأرجح منذ ما قبل تعاقدي مع كوفيد
آه في يناير أه
2020 ولم أكن أعرف ماذا
أفعل بهذه الطاقة المكتشفة حديثًا
أه الثاني كان مثل ما يجب أن
أعرفه هل يجب أن أفعل  الذهاب
للمشي هذه مشكلة جيدة لأمتلك ،
لكنني أدركت أيضًا أنه يجب عليّ
الحفاظ عليها أيضًا
لأنني أعتقد أنني دفعت نفسي قليلاً في
ذلك اليوم لأنني أعتقد
أنني كنت أكثر من ذلك قليلاً فأنت متحمس
حيال ذلك و
أنت تعلم أنني لاحظت أنه في وقت لاحق من تلك
الليلة كنت أعاني من التهاب في الرئتين
وأنا وأنت تعلم أن لدي بعض خفقان القلب
ولكن آه في معظم الأحيان ،
لقد
ظل مستوى الطاقة على حاله لمدة
أسبوع تقريبًا بعد ذلك
و  اممم والتعب بينما لا
يزال  لم يكن الأمر سيئًا
كما أن ضباب الدماغ قد اختفى ببساطة
وأم تعلم أني أود أن أقول
إنك تعلم أن هناك سببًا ولكني لا
أعرف السبب ولا أعرف
ما إذا كان العلماء يعرفون السبب
نعم ، ولكن من خلال القصص المتناقلة ، مررت أنت
والآخرون بهذه التجربة ، هل كنت
مسافرًا طويلاً ثم حصلت على جرعتك الأولى
من اللقاح وتحسنت الأمور ،
آمل أن يستمروا في
الاتجاه الصحيح في هورنيك ، شكرًا لذلك  كثير